meu nome é marlon eu tenho 23 anos cai
não eu tenho 23 anos só do são paulo mas
cresci no interior e uma receita quatro
anos
tá eu sou estudante de publicidade no
oitavo período a cigarrinha todas as
outras divas me permitir vamos formar
esse ano eu tenho essa fé
o diretor de arte opa uma agência e eu
sou frango vai tomar como
queira chamar não importa eu não tenho a
menor vergonha disso
quando era criança eu era prole mais
sensível caso a criança delicada sabem e
eu não gostava muitas brincadeiras que o
meu irmão geralmente gostava porque era
muito de briguinha lutinha eu o pão mas
eu também gostava de boneca que ainda
causam horrorosas e me dava medo rosas
nada contra quem brinca aí eu gostava de
brincar de e pula corda amarelinha e por
isso andava muito mais que as meninas
porque ela de fato brincadeiras de
menina
minha mãe ficava puto porque não era pra
cá com as meninas né eu era uma criança
muito assim muitos trejeitos eu era o
chamado a chamada criança viada já vem
falando esse termo uma criança
nada mais é do que uma criança que foge
de um comportamento que as pessoas têm
como normal
brincadeira de menino é jogar bola
brincar de boneca de luxo tinha certas
brincadeiras de menina está em casa
brincando de casinha de médicas escola
de drifting e era o que eu gostava de
fazer certo eu escuto isso antes mesmo
de nascer quando minha mãe descobriu que
vinha o menino no mundo
o enxoval caso o da minha prima ficou
rosa mas quem foi que disse que o menino
não pode usar rosa menina não pode usar
azul
estamos falando de cores quem foi que
disse que eu não poderia brincar de
amarelinha e um menino e uma menina
brincar de carrinho
esses padrões não entra na minha cabeça
porque eles não fazem o menor sentido
brinquedo não tem gênero
como esquecer de passar detalhe opa como
era criança e velho tem que comprovar
que era uma criança né
nada melhor do que fotos veja que
criança delicada fosse você olha essa
criança faz 1 continuando olha só que a
criança mais fofa meio deles e olha tá
coisa do a toda a linha e eu também
tinha um namoro nessa época foi um
namoro que durou mais que percebam a
minha felicidade nesse namoro
obrigada a gente está vendo aqui mas
ainda não a categorização de uma criança
como criança é algo bastante sério
e sintomático criança não entende de
sexualidade
essa criança e seu belíssimo por sinal
não era uma criança viada era apenas uma
criança que brincava de brinquedos e
brincadeiras que a maioria não brincava
entendem
você cresceu ouvindo dizer que ouvindo
que é uma criança viada isso te afeta
porque nunca é bom
o seu nunca é bom a tá
bom e deixa eu falar agora quando você é
criança
os seus amigos amigos seus pais eles
começam a avisar seus pais como se o
mesmo fosse cega né
e aí é a palavra bicho aparece
minha mãe não queria que eu fosse
meu pai não queria que fosse minha
avó também não tanto que ela já chegou a
falar em casa que entre um filho ladrão
e um filho viciado ela preferia qual
latão
o meu irmão me xingava de quando
chegar quando me pegava dançando em casa
não era legal e eu não queria ser
para não ser xingado ponto se em casa na
hora legal na escola muito pior
na época das trevas mais conhecida como
ensino médio eu tive que provar a minha
masculinidade
obviamente eu falei em vários pontos
eu tinha que pegar todas as meninas
o que estava na minha sala se falar
sobre o carro certo eu também tinha que
elogiar quando as meninas passassem poxa
que gostoso que não a gente não vai
rolar eu não sou essa pessoa eu tinha
que falar grosso também era bastante
complicada porque na verdade teve aquele
problema da avó sabia falar feito um
pacto
então não ia conseguir falar grosso
nunca
e como não preenche o requisito de
másculo eu fui escanteado eu sofri
bullying pelas outras meninas na no
ensino médio também encontrei pessoas
legais encontra pessoas de fato assumida
sabe lgbt assumir encontrei a figura tão
que é lésbica do homossexual que a gente
usa pejorativamente como enviado como
bicho certo e era uma pessoa como
qualquer outras porém eram pessoas muito
mais felizes e aí a gente passou a
conviver que estudava na mesma escola
passaram um tempo eo pam teve uma crise
de identidade
eu sabia que era diferente mas eu não
queria aceitar porque eu vi os meninos
levando curva todos os dias na escola na
hora do almoço ele já tinha a fama a
fama e eu não queria fazer parte disso
eu sabia que era diferente eu sabia que
era legal ser diferente mas eu tinha
medo dessas agressões e aí eu fiz o que
eu fiz não vai rolar eu virei as costas
pra ele na época o orkut eu paguei todo
mundo ficou se apague todo mundo do msn
e também fez uma limpa em casa eu
comecei pelo computador paguei todas as
músicas de que eu tinha no
computador
apague gaga britney ou beyoncé madonna
ceto do que foi desviado eu apaguei
eu passei a tentar encaixar nesse padrão
que meus amigos da escola diziam que era
o certo é que eu quero pra poder andar
com eles e eu comecei a ouvir forró e os
hawks
tá eu vi foi roque por três dias que não
aguentava mais
eu não aguentava mais a música de
é muito mais legal tem coreografia tem
as dívidas que são maravilhosas as
letras já sabia porque imaginava ele
todas as vezes de novo de rock americana
de rock mann e eu tive que baixar
tudo de novo como morava no interior
como eu falei a internet era péssima
porque baixar tudo de novo leva alguns
dias para baixar a reitora de fotografia
de novo
o tc frango de novo e aí não só as
músicas que me recuperei recuperar
também a amizade é daquelas pessoas que
eu tinha virado a cara sabe e aí eu
comecei a entender a importância de ser
uma pessoa lgbt a importância da pessoa
falar disse aceitar e falar pro outro e
sim por entender a importância de usar
um short curto que a sociedade diz que
não que eu não posso usar isso aqui
inclusive ouvir piadinhas vindo pra cá
certo e aí foi essa crença na como
convive há muito na escola com essas
pessoas com os meus amigos
obviamente você tem trejeitos que você
não consegue segurar a minha mãe é maior
mais forte que você e aí eu ia pra casa
me disse olha mostra pronta piloto a dar
razão a ela dizer foi feito o menino
ficava me censurando o tempo todo o
problema é que essa censura não fica
apenas em casa ela passa pra rua em casa
da minha mãe eu sabia que ela me amava
mas ela me dava bronca mas na rua que a
pessoa chega à ponta pra mim fala não tá
errado eu tive sorte não ser agredido
fisicamente mas já fui agredido
xingamento também agressão a agente de
todas essas piadas de todas as
derivações de frango nesta quinta
que jogue todas já estou mais acostumado
inclusive se estiverem palavras novas
medicina que eu vou matar todas elas mas
apontaram também uma arma para minha
cabeça
há um ano eu estava de mão dadas sabe
agamenon todo mundo conhece né
pronto é que jonas na frente a coisa da
fipe
estava passando com meu amigo de
mandados pra ir jantar e uma pessoa para
o nada de moto do lado resolveu sacar
uma arma apontada na cabeça e fala eu
vou matar você porque você é e aí
outra vez
é bem complicado falar disso e eu travei
estava como estava acompanhada com meu
amigo é ele falou
e aí eu travei na hora e à minha família
minha na minha cabeça eu preciso treinar
aqui eu não quero morrer agora
ítalo que estava comigo girando os
calcanhares olhou para a cara dele fez
então atira porque você vai conseguir
matar duas baixas mas não vai dar conta
de todas elas
eu também acho que tanto merece ser
aplaudida mas o meu pensamento na orla
cala boca ele está com a arma
eu fiquei travado naquilo que sou uma
pessoa de humanas mas você ingerida
agora vou falar de números o brasil
ocupa esse primeiro roso lugar quanto a
crimes registrados como homofobia tá se
ainda nesse trâmite de ela não é crime
70% desses crimes ficam impunes
o brasil ocupa o 1º lugar 2º méxico e
estados unidos
ae
a cada 27 horas uma pessoa lgbt morrem
no brasil só fazer as contas aqui
rapidinho
muita gente são 324 veículos aquilo que
eu fiz as contas da uniban mas são 320
mais 320 pessoas que morrem por nada por
crime de ódio porque são diferentes das
outras só isso
certo 2 318 mortos em 2014 segundo o
grupo gay da bahia 106 são aconteceu no
nordeste
eu culpo é a maioria desse número na
maioria mas é um personagem que fazem
cálculos não penso é é a nossa cultura
arraigada do cabra macho que você tem
que falar ou se você tem que se impôs e
tem que ser um campeão de preferência da
com uma peixeira no pulso não vai rolar
agora não tem espaço
mas rola sabe a gente ficou conhecendo
alguns meses atrás do caso
seu em orlando vocês lembram disso
infelizmente volta vou relembrar pra
quem não lembra uma pessoa decidiu
entrar na boate nos estados unidos matou
50 pessoas na boate lgbt
eu não me sinto seguro e não para as
festas que eu vou eu não me sinto segura
na rua 318 / 56 rapidinho aqui vamos
arredondar a conta seis ataques de
orlando no brasil por ano a cada dois
meses uma pessoa poder entrar na
metrópole e matar 50 pessoas
orlando é aqui que eu vou ficar calado
perante disso conseguem entender é
bastante delicada fala disso e eu não
consigo ficar rito que isso me incomoda
pessoas minhas estão morrendo pessoas de
forma geral as pessoas - estamos em nós
estamos morrendo
nós precisamos bater o pé e uma bandeira
duas 10 15 sem se for necessário eu falo
de resistência e eu falo de militância
militância cada um faz a sua o texto no
facebook que alguns de vocês criticam
ajuda está a conversa que você tem no
mercado da boa vista enquanto tomava um
sábado e você explica isso para uma
pessoa que não entende essa militância é
válida em casa no almoço qualquer
militância válida no meu caso eu fiz um
documentário chamado documentário que a
gente passa um trechinho agora
oi meu nome é joão pedro não é conhecida
com o teu eu tenho british erro lá na br
que nem meu nome é bruno eu sou bicho
tenho 24 anos e ainda não revista joão
pedro tenho 21 anos e soube fechar e eu
sou preta
meu nome é garoto de 19 anos essa drag
queen e gestão pixa meu nome aí tá bom
eu tenho 26 anos e eu não tenho a menor
vergonha de ser bicho
meu nome é orlando dantas eu tenho 22
anos e eu sou baixa
o nome dele é bicho até de no
plural
ele está disponível no youtube espero
que vocês dêem uma olhadinha depois que
ainda não viu o bicho pra mim na minha
frente e mais a brecha pra mim é é um
orgulho porque através daquele episódio
com a cabeça na rua pra vocês que passou
na agamenon ali pertinho
sabe eu não consegui ficar quieto aqui
no começo eu poderia não ter feito nada
poderia ter ficado quieto na minha mãe
me recolhida poderia ter usado roupas
longas que poderia ter voltado para
dentro daquela casa só pra dentro
daquele armário mas eu tô cansado de
ficar calado
estou cansado de uma pessoa apontada pra
mim dizer que é errado quando na verdade
minha moção short e entendeu então
resolvi chamar seus amigos inclusive um
deles aqui a randon é pra poder gravar
assim o documentário com comigo e nele
cada um dos meninos falar um pouquinho
da sua história da sua luta de todo o
processo não vou dar spoiler
mas a gente propõe nesse filme a
ressignificação da palavra porque a
gente sempre escuta a palavra
muitos de vocês já utilizaram a palavra
para ajudar outra pessoa
desculpa mas acontece desculpa tá
jogando na cara de vocês tá tem um
compromisso com a realidade em pegar
essa palavra que é utilizada com tanto
desprezo com tanto ódio com a maldição
às vezes e transformar isso numa coisa
boa
assim como está não falar agora
a partir do momento que uma pessoa chama
de e você não não se ofende com
aquilo você aceita aquilo como uma um
elogio mesmo acabou em agressão
ok queridas o bicho assim e aí obrigada
descobriu o brasil e agora vai dar diz
outra coisa aí que é isso aí não ofendeu
não como ítalo maravilhosa era foi essa
que tu atira tamar na cara dela
assim como isso não é feito mais pela
palavra como diz pra vocês podem
escolher a palavra que pra mim não cola
mais tá é olha aí o nome do filme não me
ofende mais bicho pra mim é o meu
orgulho é um é a minha bandeira é a
minha força e eu não vou aceitar que
ninguém
ninguém ninguém aponte o dedo pra mim é
que é errado porque eu vou continuar
sendo que quiser sem amor e é isso
e pra finalizar
eu queria falar que há 11 meses é nossa
não tinha a menor noção que eu estaria
hoje falando para vocês sobre militância
da operação da minha vida da vida de
alguns meninos também que quando fala
bicho que atinge algumas pessoas não
somente a mim é eu não sabia que isso ia
rolar
de fato isso é incrível porque eu tô
falando no auditório de vocês
estão vindo entender isso aqui é
maravilhoso
eu também não sabia por exemplo que
pessoas poderão ganhar prêmios por ser
rolou tá vai errou duas vezes eu é
o projeto ganhou o prêmio do intercom na
etapa regional que foi agora linha não
veio nacional mas ano que vem eu volto e
pega o que lhe dá problema nenhum e um
prémio to aqui prêmio cidadania em
respeito à diversidade dado pela appa
glbt que a associação que faz a parada
da diversidade não é parada gay fosse
uma coisa pra vocês parada da
diversidade ou parada lgbt
tá bom de são paulo que é mais conhecida
como uma das maiores do mundo e eu
também não sabia até um dia desses vou
confessar para vocês o a palavra tema
que leva a palavra que virou tema desse
evento que a resiliência que está
escrito no dicionário não só estou
dizendo que é a capacidade de uma pessoa
lidar com problemas e voltar ao seu
estado dá a volta por cima do ceará mas
como tenho a mania de ressignificar
coisas e propor novos mercados
eu queria fazer mais um acréscimo
resiliência você acreditar em você mesmo
mas antes disso você se rodeia de
pessoas incríveis que aceitam você do
jeito que você é
tá e aí você junta isso bola no bandeira
bota um troféu e mete a cara bota a cara
no sol como falando no novo vocabulário
bichice né
bota a cara não só a monna você pode
quebrar algumas vezes pode provavelmente
vai mas acho que existe na opção
como eu venho aqui
dos colegas é eu não vou desistir de ser
bicho eu tentei até você saiba que eu
tentei o meu choque não rolou
não vale a pena eu vou continuar sendo
fazer todo dia mais bicho
todo dia é assim leva mais que nem um
pokémon obrigado